hey everyone here welcome back to
another episode of watching the Watchmen
you join us on the penultimate chapter
of Watchmen today we're talking about
chapter issue 11 look on my works ye
mighty and if you're unfamiliar with the
show we are you know we do other things
with your excursions but mainly watchman
focused explicitly the Alan Moore and
Dave Gibbons and let's not forget old
Johnny Higgins as well that dream team
the cons of this masterpiece and it's
not just myself deaf has a go man yeah
check it out yep episode I mean I'm
honored to have you on really because in
in terms of the channel your channel o
views that it gets makes your colossi is
ridiculous yeah it's been mental I did
like six videos in a week cheerin which
I got verified by YouTube
that's kind so up do you know the money
the dollar signs are my eyes Tom so I'm
just like just make us butchers you do
it yeah and I got my first check through
the day from YouTube you which is really
good which is quite a like nice humbling
moment cuz I've been doing this for like
three years now and for it to really
just pay off within the last six months
has been it's been really enjoyable it's
what it's all about but I think you know
if you want your your broader definition
you'll boil definition your secret
history of the credits of definition
check those videos out they're awesome
but here we go a little deeper than we
really yeah we got a lot deeper em
actually keep an eye out for a video
I've got coming up
infinity war top eight amazing details
and Easter eggs that you missed it's not
the usual kind of Easter eggs like okay
spider-man has a blue hat I have went in
a bit deeper on it and you know when I
run out of material who do I just think
I'll just just bang how in infinity war
video so yeah check that one out it's a
lot deeper there's stuff in there like
how
Donna says he doesn't want to become a
god but he does six tasks and on the
seventh day rests and there's just I've
just try to go a bit more cerebral with
it so yeah definitely check that out
it'll be released when this video comes
out so please watch it well you know if
you want to know where we are in the
story we are way too deep fairly full of
recaps check out all the old issues that
we've gone through and you know begin
with the cover as we always do which i
think is utterly fantastic I think
probably the most beautiful of all the
covers I'd say yeah definitely it's a
really quite striking just the the
blankness of it and it's got like a
beautiful white page pretty much and the
only splash of colors really with the
butterfly and do the contrast is hard to
tell exactly what's going on off that
image yellow alone and so it really
pulls you know how it pulls you in a bit
and I do like how it's a sort of
teardrop as well yeah with she gained is
a motif of Watchmen and it's just really
nicely put together and even the clock
in the top corner you can see it's
almost at midnight and there's just
something about this page it seems very
alien compared to the other covers and
and there's something that just pulls
you in and then when you discover
exactly what's going on it's it's it's
nice there's this paradise within the
wilderness hmm as we see Karnak under
the ice yeah a lot of the covers are
matter-of-fact pragmatic a lot of them
like this are quite obscure when you
first see you don't quite know yoke of
course we learn that it's you know the
smear on the snow dome but it just seems
like a little brush of reality in this
nothingness and yeah the drops
themselves it has its own you know
environment atmosphere there kind of tea
like was well crossing the botfly
and I mean just the but hoist spray
symmetrically across this little thing
is beautiful yeah it's really nice and
again you don't really know what's going
on what's great about what most Watchmen
covers is you've got no idea how they
play into it and all that covers are
very grandiose and they end up sort of
being something very small in the
background and we pull out in at the
larger world and this is sort of again
that it look like Watchmen covers are
always sort of like looking through the
keyhole and seeing something and this is
quite it's pretty much bang on it is
even like the shape of the the viewport
is a keyhole so it's nice seeing all of
this and it pulls out and you get the
full view of what's behind the doorway
yeah and a zoom and dyers
he says towards the end of the issue I'm
not this you know serial Republic
villain sort of thing but he is
displaying you know these traits that we
see is a I think the incredibles
pastiche it very well you know the
monologues the soliloquies of these
madmen trying to legitimize the insanity
and I adore Alan Moore I discuss this
every time we do the show that I worship
Alan Moore Alan Moore I literally
consider on like a Shakespeare Beatles
level like I consider him like uber mega
genius like and he has so many modes and
I love his writing I love him writing
Ozzy wonders I think he's fantastic at
it and some of the ideas that he paints
there of Burroughs cut-up technique you
know rearranging the words they sort of
Dada Dada istic glimpse narrative that's
yeah that's kind of Watchmen Roy as a
whole
definitely and so those who who are
obtuse well who haven't got a
photographic memory and caught remember
what the Burroughs cup technique is it
basically evades rational analysis to
let the subconscious show what's
happening and they sort of highlight how
and why Osmund ice is just letting all
knowledge stream and flow through him so
as a whole he can view the overall
narrative and it is I did say it last
episode but it is awesome and Isis
attempt to become a God and almost to
gain the foresight that dr. Manhattan
has and by doing this and it's nice that
he's sort of trying to elevate himself
and it is just it shows the genius of
his his villainy which is something that
I kind of don't think Doomsday Clock has
managed to do he just seems kind of like
a bit of a [ __ ] in that yeah
this you really do get the idea that
especially throughout this issue as well
that he is just so above everyone else
that comes to face him bar John and it
just really elevates him as it threat
because of it
absolutely and he orchestrates you know
this entire graphic novel where in
Doomsday Clock he's more of you know
along with marionette and all the rest
you just kind of kind of bear and you
know we've done dooms they've got pretty
much up to a it's servicing I think I
think we are at today we've done all of
it and as he's speaking for us he's
talking about the white noise and of
course you know the snow covering the
swirling chaos of the world here
I love the smokestack is well that's
smothered with half of the forest yeah
it is like this location it's very
unique mmm and there's a lot of intrigue
here I've never really seen something
quite like amongst the snow there's this
beautiful almost Garden of Eden like
paradise and later Ottoman diet has no
qualms in destroying it which sort of
speaks to his feelings on the world as a
whole no matter how beautiful something
is or it could be he knows that just
wiping it clean is the best way to go
and it is quite an interesting piece as
a whole that we get the perspective of
the villain and a lot of comics you
would never really see the film's
perspective on things so it's quite
creative that mores given us this entire
issue where he is the main focus and a
lot of the things that happen we see it
through his eyes absolutely and the
final image of page one we're seeing for
his eyes is more employing that take
technique yet again as probably what we
get this and smokestacks the sense of
perspective moving backwards
I like how as the dome is covered yet
another of you know Adrian incredible
creations comes into view the smoke
stack of Bubastis is on stalks their
horns and if the bus is an interesting
character in this and I want to just
point again to the writing here more is
almost he's kind of doing that all work
for us especially with this where he's
watching the two riders approaching it
must be so disorientating their pursuit
leads them deeper in tomorrow
intellectual regions as unshot and
devoid of landmarks as a territory
currently surrounding them yeah it's
just brilliant hmm and as they're sort
of traveling along you do really get the
size and scale of exactly what they're
heading into Watchmen up to this point
has been very small-scale almost it's
been minor murders people getting
infected with cancer but this is sort of
them building up to the final reveal
they're heading in the wilderness and I
do quite like the way that was human
diet also admires them and that there's
some bits of dialogue that I don't want
to go too much in on Doomsday Clock book
you can really see the difference
between was writing in John's so when he
says the ice is thin and slippery as
they slide on it what makes that work as
opposed to Johnson Doomsday Clock
is the ice is thin and like that is a
proper saying it doesn't sound forced
right where is something in Jones's work
it seems like he's forced an idiom in
order for the the panel to display what
is happening the same way with that that
bed thing a common book exactly what it
worked but was something about him being
chained up I'd rather be chained down oh
yes yeah yeah and it's just like Jones's
try to coin these phrases that don't
actually exist whereas more as you do so
yeah it's nice and I'd love like the way
we follow along the sugar cube wrapper
as that blows into the wind and you just
get the feeling that they're heading out
on its last journey it is like watching
two two Cowboys ride off into these into
the sunset almost but obviously it's
it's not enough environment it's in a
[ __ ] Antarctica I don't know why I
swear they really let myself down this
no I I just I'm just amazed when I look
over this obviously we're doing the
episodes we have in front of us and I
just I think it is a masterpiece I'm
trying to read a little bit more into
the sugar cube I think it's kind of
caped like or I don't know if it's meant
to evoke the the splash earlier of
reality is just something sort of
disjunctive
from the surroundings but and and the
fact that we see the building as well I
never really noticed that but you see
the building was at the houses of
parliament
yeah the sort of distant by lines and
the gust is a vote fantastic and we get
back into Carnac with Adrian and I love
the close of this where he's basing in
no time like the present you know the
plan is coming into action and you know
we get the idea of the past above him as
the image like this time he's in prison
and then the multiple times that are
present Tokyo in London in New York yeah
no it's great and you don't really pick
up that those are his targets at the
moment but it's it's nice that he's kind
of got these in the background and
you've also got Alexandra and a massive
painting on his wall and is that the
Gordian knot I've known I've only
noticed it now yeah it's just kind of
showing how obsessed he is with this
rational thinking and the logical
thinking I think I don't know exactly
what the terminology for it is but just
to solve things by cheating them almost
which is what he does so the Gordian
knot is basically there was a nun table
knot and people spent ages trying it was
basically a sword in the stone sort of
scenario and Alexandra just showed up
and cut it just cut the knot so you do
get this the fact that was human dies
admires that so much it shows that he is
willing to cheat and do things they
shouldn't really do to attain his goals
we see the nuclear waste projector as
well telling the Bubastis it doesn't
want to approach this machinery very
telling as well the aussies bathed in a
blue light as he presses the bond yeah
definitely and this is him actually like
setting the the bomb off is known but
there's just no real impact to it here
you did kind of a thing what's he doing
yeah yeah and it's nice I do like the
way that the time is structured in this
issue especially when it comes out to
reveal at the end that human dies has
already killed everyone and it's
pointless
I'm like Dan and Rorschach even
attempting to stop them because they're
too late yeah yeah and it reminds me a
little bit of the intrinsic field
chamber that we see on the the Gila
flats yes so yeah like I'm kind of
jumping ahead a bit here but to me it
makes me the most sense what they did in
the film where they tied it in at dr.
Manhattan I mean what do you think of
the would you want to leave that till
the big vagina is over yeah I kind of
admired that it was a different ending
and they took a different direction
awful it was kind of cool in them itself
but yeah as a die-hard I I didn't want
them to play more into the squid thing
but the squid things mentioned isn't it
this like sense or in joke with the name
of something alright yeah some sort of
missile is called out something I can't
remember okay we'll get to that and you
know we will do the film eventually as
well maybe at the end of this long
journeys been like a year we've been
reviewing Watchmen so you know thank you
to all the tens of listeners that are
out there and definitely go back to some
of your favorite stuff here which you
know thankfully ends in this issue it's
the black freighter you know what I
actually do think the the black
freighter works expertly in this issue I
know I made it in the past and but it's
sublime here just the way that I think
it's in a world with a narrative with
the news of Endor and basically in it
the pirate murders the village whilst
they sleep and the same thing sort of
happens to the New York citizens though
not on a literal sense I they've been
asleep to the world around them and they
killed off because of their ignorance
and what happens in the black freighter
it's like two people arriving to
basically the same conclusion that they
need to kill these sleeping people
because they don't realize what monsters
they became and I do like the way that
as he's murdering the these people and
in the black freighter comic - two
riders show up right and arrived to the
scene horrified and that mirrored in the
same way that night owl in and Rocher
you know yeah didn't even realize that
right Paul yeah and we also get some
some lesbian distress well yeah we do
it's very very strange so I'm sure I
remembered this like not being very
homophobic right but rereading it kind
of was a bit but don't yeah it's it's
very strange
yes what do you think about it I'm
surprised I'm pointing against at the
end yeah I don't know why like I
remembered it as everyone's having a
fight people all come together to break
it up and then they all kind of have a
moment where they they join together and
realize that they're not so different in
that working together they can get
everything done and then they're
brutally murdered but it doesn't really
happen like that
I'm so it was a bit strange rereading it
I don't know if I haven't just got such
an idyllic view of the world that I just
always see the best in people
well we have more transitions here we
have a splash at coffee as well which
evokes Malcolm to me but I it's a little
to no cheeky boy more it's not as clever
by his standards but I still like it
this all poster of the tropics going
into the Dom mm-hmm and there are still
nice touches here like the fact that
he's kept these ideas going this long
and they're still really creative
inhibit innovative she just shows how
well thought-out and educated he is as a
person
wonderful work by all made John Higgins
on the upper page seven here I think
y'all see four and the whole book he's a
master but I I love this you know a lot
of what Dave humans as what I love
seeing Bubastis chased after this exotic
animal that the dogs has water fountains
the frog on the frommed magnificent yeah
it's really nicely put together and
again when we were talking to a friend
of the podcast Ron Higgins yeah I did
say only I do prefer these abstract
colors to the more photorealistic ones
that are available now and this is just
a great example of it it's very there's
not that many colors here but what
Higgins has done with with it is it's
great and
you do really get like a contrast when
you look in the rest of the book it just
this scene feels so alien to the the
harsh streets of New York you get the
idea of two alien universes separated by
a membrane of fragile glass yeah really
really nice and I like how that we
finally get as human dices backstory
mm-hmm and so he comes from immigrant
parents who died when he was 17 and his
idolization of alexandre the great
inspires him to unite the world so from
this he burns his fortune and sets out
to remake it from nothing which is quite
like admirable really yeah but yeah it's
just a very strange way to go about it
and I do like how when he's discussing
his like origins you get the view
looking you got by him from the bottom
of the pond like we are almost like pond
life beneath him and then this
transitions in a very human story at the
newsstand and it's just nice that these
two human stories cohabit world coexist
basically in the same group um yeah just
really well done it really really is and
I love the way that panel a is spread
we're almost imagined a five on a die no
sorry the for separating on the north
south east and west is yellow wet and
changing you know from boy into observer
into you know someone born again and you
often see it's very typically I'm
thinking of like welcome to the jungle
by Guns N'Roses when Axl comes off the
bus the country hick with a bit of corn
in his mouth and it's nice to see him
chewing on corn as sitting on his
parents grave yeah they're really good
and it's just really well put together
and it makes them infinitely more
fascinating yeah those ones saying he
goes by saying it's well put together
doesn't it it's like we don't even need
to highlight this anymore
like it just yeah every single panel you
know he's fantastic and we spend a lot
of time with Josephine is that right
Joseph Joey sorry Joey in a link yeah
yeah like I can imagine this was
revolutionary at the time and even today
is
to get gay aspects and characters and
comic books and so you know what really
annoys me is when they do have gay
characters there's always kind of a big
song and dance about it
where is what I will you know commend
more for is it's very subtle here and
there's a sort of normality to it and
that you know does show how progressive
more is where is more modern comics like
oh we've got a gay character we're so
edgy and progressive whereas mores not
really even highlighting it that much to
be honest I mean they're a gay couple
but beyond that it doesn't really need
anything you know this that what the
scenario here could easily be a
heterosexual couple basically running
the end I suppose when Joey just says I
want to be straight yeah which again is
a bit I don't know communis was a
character it's just necessarily more
worldview like yeah no you're right it's
just very strange to come that
left-field at the end but I don't know
and and as we're pulling in as our eyes
are being drawn to the Knotts book being
torn in half
which you know yeah whatever it's not
it's not amazing but we're seeing behind
the sort of electrical charger the Void
mentions later that made is fortune okay
right yeah I didn't even notice that
nice that the Koontz reading black
freighter is leaning on and we go back
into the book funnily nothing she just
reminds me and the whole black freighter
of the blank dossier by League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen ready yeah boy
actually yeah it's really good actually
it's kind of just like a sort of source
book but it's a story within of two
agents stealing it and they read it like
the black freighter and we get to go in
and it's like one of the things is a
fake Shakespeare play about Prospero
from The Tempest that magician who was
like the original member of the league
and like they're being found and
Elizabethan times and yeah it's it's
[ __ ] incredible I might do an episode
actually and maybe upload it on the
channel
okay pay extra because I really do want
to talk about this at length it and it's
got 3d glasses as well it ends in a four
dimensional world
and I have the Quigley glasses on and
you know it's crazy but we'll get on to
that and we get more of Ozzy becoming
Ozzy and you've reminded me a bit of
black freighter the image of him in the
water right yeah definitely and that is
alluded to heavily when the guy from the
black freighter sure just call on pirate
man yeah pirate man returns to the water
at the end and I'll do like how as he's
retracing Alexandra's footsteps that he
talks about using drugs to go to a
higher form of consciousness which is
something that more and Grant Morrison
often allude to and they're creating
work like especially Grant Morrison um
is yeah he didn't if you would Kevin
Smith I think where he talked about how
he came up with loads of comic ideas
just on LSD and yeah it's nice that more
continues this aesthetic of make sure
you do drugs kids it's good yeah sorry
go on
no I'm just the the statue a silhouette
of Ozzy as well in this page we pretty
much never seen in front on yeah it's
true we're always behind him and that is
the case with those human dies
especially in this book where the heroes
are a so far behind him he's always one
step ahead and so it's nice that that's
portrayed in the work as well and you
know like the Pharaohs he mentions who's
you know secrets died with this with the
slaves in San so tubes here you know the
same things happening right but I guess
that means snow that's gonna smuggle the
dome yeah that's true and I do like how
you don't even realize his servants are
dead they're just kind of sitting there
yeah and then a butterfly lands or one
of the heads right yeah no that's right
yeah good good good spot though on the
fly you just saw that's the beauty of
this comic you know this song would you
stop there's probably so much great
stuff we haven't spoken about oh yeah no
we and that's just you know by virtue of
not looking for loose enough I guess but
yeah we learned about Ozzy's world and
you know what he does throw tom he picks
up a nap
as he leaves the paradise which are kind
of took as an allusion to the Apple
being picked from the Garden of Eden in
Genesis and then that destroyed the
parasite at the Paradise because you
know knowledge has its negatives Tom
he's not he's not Road no he's an apple
isn't it yeah it was a rose as around
the stem of the computers hands that he
has which is a nice touch as well and
you know he does have a sidekick in
Bubastis like like like a Robin like a
Superdog yeah meant any look Bubastis if
you get a Funko pop over mo a 700-pound
on eBay I don't know who can afford
these expensive Funko pops Tom I bought
a 30-pound one today and the wife wasn't
happy when she seen and he's he's crazy
well I love these sequins I think this
is one of the most breathtaking moments
when the snow fills the dome and the
animals evacuate into the barren
wilderness yeah
any chance it just looks crazy isn't it
yeah they're all gonna die they're all
kind of running for their lives but
they've got no control over their fate
really which is what's happening in New
York as well yeah yeah the face of
humanity is being quite essentially as
we close the issue and lovely transition
between the servants face and the
floating course yeah no they didn't even
notice that so yeah again it ties into
the the black freighter beautifully and
he's it's the pirate man he's just
walking out into the sea because he sees
he sees the black freighter in the
distance and he realizes it's became a
monster
you should go go join it yeah oh it's
great real fantastic ending I think yeah
definitely and it does fine kind of
redeem the rest of the work they do it
how much of it there is obviously we
could count it what do you reckon is
that two issues worth maybe the issue
yeah I'd say there's probably about an
issue worth yeah and we do we should
check out the
may it yes yeah quite pin forward to see
in that that's the only part of Watchmen
that haven't seen um I do have the
Ultimate Edition which i think is a lot
better than the theatrical cut there's
there's like there's so many different
versions I think there's three different
versions of the film I'm sorry about the
director's cut so the there's the
theatrical then the director's cut which
is the 3-hour one and then there's the
Ultimate Edition which has got the black
freighter in as well and you know we get
so much of Ozzy's power in a sense
juxtaposed by the somewhat hapless
Encounters of Rorschach and night owl
you know trying to burn out lock
mechanisms admitting that they're
nervous and a wonderful quote here from
Noel this must be how ordinary people
feel this one this must be how ordinary
people feel around us
yeah but ya know this gets cool I like
it
yeah because it kind of its kind of true
for a lot of just superhero mythology in
general like you can apply that to
anything really and I just yeah it's
beautiful
mhm definitely and we do kind of see
that they also get out matched when they
do about all those human dies as well oh
god they get their ass kicked and yeah
yeah I still wince when the shield it
Rorschach's like knows yeah like there's
only a few fight scenes in Watchmen um
but this one is is brilliant it's just
so well put together I
veidt's divulging how he studied the
comedian or was fending them off and and
yeah it's just the guys just totally out
matching them in every way he's having a
dinner having a conversation and still
kicking the [ __ ] out of them he knows
they're coming but he still does his
mouth yeah exactly he just doesn't care
he's ready for it he's so prepared he
knows the two of them own come just no
match for him at all he's he's swatting
flies basically he's I think the rules
are the NOI house shoots him that's a
white Dom I think it's like a flashlight
or something like trying to blind him
and he also talks about how when he
first met the comedian they had a fight
which is something that is like a plot
device in comics like ever since
Superman met Batman for the first time
and they had a fight pretty much every
hero fights another hero the first time
they come across them and it's nice that
more recognizes this staple of comics
and kind of breaks it down like it's
just yeah I like I like that because
it's sort of laughing at it and it's
weird that the comedian beats yeah
awesome and ice as well from that
obviously plays off again in Doomsday
Clock but yes it's it's nice how you've
got this fight going on whilst you're
also learning things so it's not just
action when I'm reviewing comics are
often criticize them if they're just
mindless action whereas this isn't like
boys fight scenes are really really good
on an intellectual level and sort of an
exciting level yeah absolutely we get to
see is sheer brute strength
howdy few beds the fork Rorschach trying
to get out and then Rorschach jumping
behind him as he blocks it yeah as he's
talking about the comedian's history
with JFK and I suppose this is true I
haven't fact-check this but he doesn't I
can't imagine not being false about
Gentiles suppose its speech that day
before the inevitable Dealey Plaza
accident where he mentions you know we
in this country in this generation are
by destiny rather than choice the
Watchmen on the walls of world freedom
yeah no that's great and that's probably
where more got the name from yeah yeah
yeah he's right to think that it's
rumored from the speech Kennedy was
supposed to give on that day yeah that's
crazy like that's how in depth Moore's
knowledge is as well like you would
definitely know all this kind of stuff
and so yeah it's just it's a great call
um and it's sort of highlights exactly
how the Watchmen themselves are failures
like they're meant to be something
that's delivered and by the government
but they're just they're not quite that
then they're not they're you know I mean
something's always gonna be in their way
to stop them from being the heroes which
is basically what happens in this book
they they are failures that they are the
end of the book
yeah and I'd love to see you know
melding of amalgamation of all these
scenes of this initial meeting you know
of the Minutemen and it's just yeah so
fascinating to see from all the
different angles and again we see Dan
ship flying off from one of the later
panels the crossword like buildings and
you know the comedian with Laurie and
Sally as well that encounter so just the
sense of filmic perception the sense of
the scenes being alive it's really rich
yeah it's definitely just the the amount
of different perspectives and how much
different light they shed on that one
moment as well it's really
well-developed like you can't really
it's it's I don't think there's anything
that's sort of encapsulated it in a film
like that level of detail just watching
the same scene over and over from
different perspectives and every time
you're getting a new take on it is
really just a genius concept and the
fact that it delivers so much is this
really just it shows why this book went
on because like so gain to so many
awards and is still ranked up as one of
the best graphic novels of all time yeah
absolutely and we get that you know
they're recovering and the five I
mentioned before that's quite hideous
really we see Malcolm you see Reggie's
parents potentially reuniting here and
you know the idea that Malcolm exists in
this world this you know his fate that
he's accepted here you know please
understand you know talking about the
world itself the wall that he's like
this you know I can't run from it yeah
and I do like it because Malcolm is a
good person like Rorschach criticized
him earlier for thinking that he is a
good person but he's not actually one
but I do think this shows in his final
moments that he was a good person and he
does try to help people no matter wha
and he it wasn't just fame-hungry when
he went after Rorschach he did just want
to help him
great see the dead but flying outside
the window ya know that that's a really
good show as well I when I read I'm
someone who kind of tends to focus more
on the words in comics rather than the
art it's south
you kind of skim the panels but this is
worth looking at the panels for like
over and over just to kind of see what
you're missing cuz there's so much
detail in it yeah I mean even the guy's
fears
Bubastis approach or you know even just
curiosity about what this thing is like
it's maybe they've seen it before and
seen it this size you do see the message
it says well when Ozzy's watching the
assassination yeah as like a little cat
or maybe that's someone else but I like
to think the moment it's Bubastis but
you know very very cool and the plan
gets explored the ideas new foraged and
it's fascinating reading isn't it the
first time really when you reread it
just seeing all the cogs moving yeah
it's brilliant
um and I do like how you know as human
diet was the only actual villain that
could have been but I can imagine the
first time people read this that it just
wasn't obvious till really this issue
and yeah it's just night and then we get
the lovely big vagina Aryan just drops
and I love the fact that the black
freighter ends out of its panel and we
have the end hanging there above the two
women here in each other it's glorious
ya know that's true
another again like I've missed so much
of this just by trying to focus on the
text because it's a very text heavy
issue this one as well like pretty much
every panel has like four paragraphs in
it and but yeah that there's so much
going on and yeah what's done it you've
done it again is it genius we see the
cops you know we see other characters we
barely know about drivers etc and it's
just it's it's great storytellers you
know Qi I suppose have this intersection
where everything is where the restaurant
is just opposite the empty in concert or
pale horse that we've heard about
earlier next to the Ganga diner as I
mentioned before but it doesn't feel
forced no to me at least it doesn't feel
forced at the fact that everything sort
of happens in these key areas it doesn't
feel forced
whereas some films or books I think
suffer from characters just
coincidentally bumping into one another
this feels like a real real life
breathing city where they aren't
coincidences they're just part of life
John is a vote of course and John you
know ironically a sort of inspiration
for the whole thing proving the
teleportation could be done yeah
which again it's it's one thing lead
having a knocking on effect on the other
and if John hadn't been basically if the
Superman hadn't have existed we would
have probably lived in a lovely peaceful
world like we've got now Tom and you
know we see that gonna be going at
Elephant above as well the plan is
revealed the idea of him having sympathy
for the Keene act him enacting his
revenge on comedian as well and you know
I I love that idea that it was
professional jealousy yeah yeah because
it's the only man who beat him really
and which might be why he's kind of in
Doomsday Clock trying to be a dr.
Manhattan as well I need his stuff
talking about Doomsday Clock it's the
the ruined my memory of Watchmen is now
a number re down my Doomsday Clock
though but it does suck he had too long
now to get good I was still gonna read
it was still gonna review it but you
know I'm still gonna buy the absolute
edition in five years yeah just just a
Funko is you'd buy them right I probably
would come I bought a I bought a 10-inch
Stannis won a day well it's absolutely
massive
yeah that was quite good I don't know
why I like Funko pops one of my friends
came around he's really in a Lego and he
spends like 200 pound on LEGO sets a
month I mean he came around he was like
I don't understand Funko pops as I will
I don't understand Lego but you know we
like the things we like Tom we do we do
I'm not Loki him a big Lego fan as Waldo
canción much but you don't yeah you
don't enjoy the therapeutic nature
not really no I like to bring it all
down just own it put it on the 10 inches
smush yeah it's too big of anything it's
distracting
its massive in the room we learn more
about the you know the the psychiatric
reports that the cancer plots Hitler is
invoked here you know people swallow
lies easily recorded they're big enough
and it moves forward you know the text
starts to come away and the last two
panels are wordless as Ozzy reveals what
we saw prior that he he's already done
it he set off the big vagina alien
hasn't he it's gone it's gone out so so
they're now caught can't take it back
you can't be like are as human dies
could you know of just like pretended it
was dr. Manhattan either did in the
movie you can't do that now because he's
already put it out there big vagina
whoa so he presses the button and the
bomb teleports and then dalian comes out
the far wall it's like a psychic attack
isn't it so it it pops out and the
aliens a bomb though because the alien
is there yeah yeah so he teleports the
alien which has got a psychics brain in
it which upon teleportation explodes
psychic energy think I don't know if
this is right you know so but that yeah
oh no Tom no I'm just looking the alien
alien vagina bomb that shoots out
psychic energy that also has dr.
Manhattan's teleportation abilities that
is gonna kill everyone but make everyone
who survives wanna fight more big vagina
aliens in case there are any more big
vagina aliens stasis but there isn't so
as we end ooh it reminds me a little bit
of like Frank quietly the way he tends
to do panels and
you know I love it really I loved seeing
all these faces as the implosion ears
and seeing the the man and the boy
braces there incinerated it's moving
yeah it just makes me think that it's
more simplistic I blame it on Manhattan
he was already feared and disliked and
just say you know what dr. Manhattan he
accidentally set off some bombs with his
energy signature and I liked the movie
more Tom Wow I liked the movie more than
more thing happens when you say you like
the movie more to Alan Moore I haven't
watched a film and I can imagine he
wouldn't he does like cinema to a
certain extent I think I think I say you
Anarkali ages ago about stuff he's
watched anyway a few seriously a piece
of The Sopranos was quite good but I
think if we ever do get him on the
podcast we should waste his time
completely and just ask him questions
that we already know that and the answer
to like so what did you think about
Watchmen I haven't seen it so so what
did you think about me for vendor had
then have you seen that I haven't seen a
lend yet cut on : blue surprised you
haven't seen it Alan it's your work you
should check it out I might be late
latest Netflix trend of them buying like
a whole back catalogs of comic guys so
having Mark Miller Rob Liefeld I'm not
saying the mall would ever do it in his
lifetime but it would be pretty [ __ ]
cool back I don't know they probably a
Netflix quality Tom strong or or they
remade Watchmen I don't know if he's up
to that yeah like preacher was yeah
massively hyped and that was pretty [ __ ]
is bad our first season just to say
before the story but I never get
prequels Tom why did I set it before the
story you know no I mean that's not
where the story is that it's never gonna
work name name three good prequels you
can't so that's everyone's comment I
tell you what we haven't had many
comments so if you want to leave a
comment named
really good prequels ago I'll let you
have anything that's I'm being generous
anyway back in this book the
supplementary material it's an interview
with white in Antarctica and it sort of
works as a bit of a puff piece like but
it actually feels like it was really
written by journalists yeah BAM they
talked about how like whites got Vietnam
stuff show was kind of that to me sort
of shows how America enslaved Vietnam
after winning the war and when it
discusses once again how he's a guard
and we've kind of theorized that the
Nova Express is secretly owned by
Ozymandias and this sort of lets you
know exactly how the articles gonna
paint him out to be and he just says
he's a genuinely nice guy and you need
to check him out and if he talks about
how like the power is within everyone to
achieve the extraordinary and you know
the discipline within exercise is
transferable as a mind state that allows
you to dedicate yourself something which
is actually something I agree with Tom I
used to be quite a [ __ ] you remember
them days Tom when I was the right file
I've seen it I seen images yeah exactly
and I just thought one they are just so
I need to lose weight and so that the
dedication that you need to have to lose
weight it does transfer over and other
things I think that's why I'm like sort
of anything I put my mind to I think I
can do it and the same with this YouTube
[ __ ] Tom do you think do you think most
people would have sat for three years
getting 20 views on their four hour-long
podcast and would have kept go and Tom
cuz I don't think the word so anyone out
there who wants to do something
persistency is always the key to
anything if you just keep doing
something even if there's 400 other
people doing it chances are 90% of them
after three years they're gonna stop
doing it
who's gonna still be doing it you you've
wiped out your competition just by
staying around longer so I just want to
shower or human dies for this article
from this mind state the he mentions
John he puts John down actually you know
the origin of his powers bulimia selfish
to say in your potential is the first
step to realizing that potential
alternatively you could do as John did
fall into a nuclear reactor and hope for
the best
yeah it also discusses like
crime-fighting in the morality of the
law and it's probably the best some
supplementary material part of the book
in all honesty like yeah it's nice yeah
yeah yeah enjoyed it I would actually
read this yeah we feel we should do
something maybe next issue we should
rank all the supplementary material or
at least go over it quickly because some
of the I do actually really like like
under the hood but yes some of it is a
bit more the damn out one is a bit weird
and doesn't really reveal anything but
you know they're all insightful in their
own ways and the times they are
a-changin is how we end lost our driver
and you know literally figuratively they
are and the invocation as well a Bob
Dylan is you know very watchful ask I
should say as well the quote at the end
my name is Ozymandias king of kings look
on my works ye mighty and disappear and
despair is by Percy Bysshe Shelley Mary
Shelley afar verse or you know legendary
rocontour poet in his own way and and
someone that I think Moore himself was
gone on record saying that it's quite a
big fan of him like yeah that quote gets
used quite a lot as well I think it was
an alien covenant it's been in God of
War that was like the secret code that
if you unlock that was like that's where
I know it from anyway Tom I'm not on it
I'm not an intellect I know it from God
of War but yeah it's it's nice I like it
and that's it that's issue 11 where did
it go one more fine it's all good man
one final one yet we'll be back soon for
episode 12 may be doomsday falafels
shortly after that hopefully not but you
notably we're gonna have to cover it
yeah do you wanna show anything out Tom
because I know we always talk about me
but you went quite viral
recently as well haven't you oh yeah
well uh yeah about our resume yeah
things I do yeah I had
yeah well I had the main man a [ __ ]
UK Berra on the show sort of free our
show or explains everything
what did you think about death did you
get a chance to hear it
I did top my blessing there were quite a
few times quite funny um
I enjoyed it really in it well I was
four he was there I was I think my aunt
man in the wasp post-credit scene
explained video dropped the same day
right and I was sort of having a bit of
a competition with the other he's got
more views than his and he had a hammer
at more which is nice isn't it Tom it's
nice that I hate you so much that
anytime you're successful I'm angry
about it so I took a real hard look for
myself that day but yeah you do really
well so I definitely recommend people
check that out even if they're not fans
of battle rap it's sort of like it's
more sort of a business podcast isn't it
really and about how yeah like the
breakdown of a business how that can
affect people and so it is a really
interesting listen not just for battle
rap purposes but just business in
general and kind of things that you need
to look out for and what's most
interesting is is that it was a business
between friends um and I've always kind
of thought if I ever did a business I
would not work with any of my friends
because I'd probably become you know I
mean would fall out over stuff you just
saw what happened and it's nice together
kind of perspective on stuff yeah there
was no precedent really for what
happened and also don't listen to the
episode listen if you're a fan of me I
genuinely speak about two sentences in
the entire don't worry about that Tom I
don't think there's many no those were
always there Tim adventures but you know
this is their new show at the end of the
day I'm just I'm just trying to get
people out there as a platform so so
yeah this has been great as if a please
email us as we are nearing the end of
this dozen watching The Watchmen part do
you want to come comment below as well
of course subscribe to this channel
check out our resume as well definitely
any final thoughts shouts myself it's a
good night from me it's a good night
from quick yes
you